all right CB is with us CB is in San
Antonio ICB how are you pretty good I
have a shrill better than I deserve sir
what's up in your world
alright man I in the four years that
I've been out of high school I have
managed to rack up forty five thousand
dollars in debt um the reason I'm
calling is because I'm trying to get rid
of my car I'm pretty in the hole you
know I'm about $10,000 in the hole on my
car I think I could sell it for 25 but I
really don't like what happens with the
money that's that's left over you know
what once you sell the car what do you
make a year uh about seventy thousand
you and your four years out of high
school what do you do uh I'm a mechanic
in South Texas I travel around in the
oil field work on oh oh you got a good
income you just been doing some stupid
stuff right oh well yeah as soon as I
got a high school man I got that first
paycheck and uh yeah it's kind of a
little crazier gotcha
okay well uh what'd you say the car is
worth twenty-five but you owe 35 on it
well yeah I feel like the first time I
bought a car and I decided I didn't like
the car my right and you roll the
negative equity into it yeah yeah and
then I got another car and then I said
well I don't like this one either and I
traded in and this is the car that I'm
on that file I don't act up on to it you
know so most of the stupids been around
car trades
yes sir pretty much now so have you
learned your lesson
oh yeah yeah okay it's cost you enough
money I hope so
all right if you saved it have you saved
any money at all honestly I mean I've
been just throwing everything I really
have I got about three thousand dollars
right now in the bank but I mean I've
been throwing everything they have at
what well I had a motorcycle before and
I just recently paid that off last week
what's it worth it's worth about five
thousand okay
and the
all right do you have anything else you
have any other money saved other than
3,000 uh no sir I mean just retirement
plan and everything but that's that's
about it I mean 3,000 that's that's all
I got really how's your credit I mean it
should be good I've never I've never
missed a payment or anything I'm who's
the one who's alone with on the car
security service I believe okay um all
right well here's the thing we have to
have the $10,000 because the way the
transaction works is if I'm buying the
car I give you a check for 25,000 right
yes sir and then you have to give the
car company or the security services
people a check for 35,000 or to get the
title to give to me you hurt you follow
me so we got to have that ten grand you
can either borrow that ten grand or you
can save it up or you can pay the car
down aggressively and go from there well
that's that's kind of what I've been
doing like I paid that motorcycle off so
what I'm planning on throwing the
motorcycle keep paying the motorcycle
payment just on the car I just didn't
know if it would be a good time to sell
I didn't really know what happened to
that negative you know yeah you got it
made you know you can see they're
holding your title until you give them
35 gyfer and you got to give the title
to the new buyer who's only going to
give you a 25 yes sir so we got to find
that other ten and the way to do that's
pay the car down from 35 to 25 or save
up the ten or borrow the ten yep
but no more impulsive decisions on
vehicles well if I were you I would stop
your retirement and I would get on a
tight budget beans and rice rice and
beans and I'd stop saving money
I mean I'd stop spending money or saving
money on anything and I would get in
attack mode
attack mode attack mode yeah and yeah
yeah I'd get after that and let's get
rid of this thing and get your life back
as soon as you possibly can and then
save up and pay cash for whatever you do
from this point forward okay yep are mmm
hey thanks for the call we appreciate
you listening hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you